well it's been nine years since oh bring
Gayle went on their road trip but as we
said earlier our favorite dynamic duo is
given something even better yes I love
this it's called the og Chronicles og as
in Oprah and Gayle and it's a series on
Oprah Maggie answer all kinds of
relationship questions from fans I am
all in images this is I mean
unbelievable all right well here is
Oprah and Gayle stance on sex on the
first date sleeping together on the
first date yes or no no no overt are we
old so what we are old we're not old
we're just experienced yeah for the
record both Oprah and Gayle are 64 why
buy the cow when he can get the milk for
free
not that we're cows I'm not saying that
but I just think it changes the dynamic
but guy knows who will sleep with him on
the first date the February issue of O
Magazine goes deeper and tackles the
issue of online dating of course
Oprah's off the market but what about
Gayle would she use tinder we're told
she's never tried it but would be open
to it listen women like sex - we
exercise discretion we have a good time
and it leads to good things
[Music]
[Applause]